now to capitol hill republicans who have
opposed the president's vaccine mandates
could shut down the government this
weekend in protest but other republicans
including senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell say it's not worth it to close
the government lawmakers who support the
shutdown idea say they'll block a budget
bill that must pass by tomorrow night
unless the administration drops its
vaccine mandates over the past week a
handful of judges have rejected parts of
the biden vaccine mandates
the supreme court is set to decide
whether to overrule one of the most
historic decisions the justices heard
arguments yesterday over a mississippi
law that bans abortion after 15 weeks of
pregnancy this is the most significant
challenge to roe v wade in decades jan
crawford is at the supreme court with
audio of some of the questions that the
justices asked jan good morning to you
they sure had a lot of questions
yesterday
they did gail and you know based on
those questions i think that it appears
right now the court is inclined to allow
that mississippi 15-week ban but it's
not at all clear they're going to take
the next step and overturn roe versus
wade
protesters from across the country on
both sides came to make their voices
heard
inside the courtroom liberal justices
argued roe versus wade is too
established to overturn 50 years of
decisions
saying that this is part of our law that
this is part of the fabric of
women's existence in this country and
would put at risk the court's legitimacy
will this institution
survive the stench
that this creates
in the public perception
that the constitution
and its reading
are just political acts chief justice
john roberts suggested the court could
uphold the mississippi law which
prohibits abortion after 15 weeks
without overturning roe
if you think that the issue is one of
choice
that women should have a choice to
terminate their pregnancy why would 15
weeks be an inappropriate line but that
still would be a major shift from its
last big abortion case in 1992 when the
court drew that line at viability around
24 weeks
mississippi's only abortion clinic now
at the center of the fight performs
abortions up to 16 weeks where does the
line get drawn a lawyer from mississippi
said the issue should be up to the
states which struck a cord with justice
brett kavanaugh why should this court be
the arbiter
rather than
congress the state legislatures state
supreme courts the people
being able to
resolve this
but predicting how the court is going to
decide this case is really impossible
because no matter how it might look
today the justices can always change
their minds when they're deliberating
behind the scenes so if you hear anybody
saying that they know the court is going
to overturn roe or they're not going to
just tell them you don't know what's
going to happen between now and june
when we expect a decision in this case
nate
jan thank you so much